the emperor is back in his kingdom  growing up is never easy but in nature  schoolyard and article offers a  particularly tough education yet for the  emperor penguin the most uninhabitable  place on earth is called  marching far and away into the  mysterious unknown discovering love  embracing fatherhood fighting for  survival  [Music]  setting the whole  [Music]  forced through unforgiving yet  mesmerizing landscapes propelled by an  ancient call to the scene  [Music]  this is the story of two destinies one  with a lifetime of experience and the  other just beginning the old Emperor  gives way and the story of a new emperor  begins  march of the Penguins to the next step  [Music]  you